[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja Hayali
[Musik]
gut und wir beginnen mit einer Frage
kommt ein erneuter Ausstieg vom Ausstieg
nachdem wir ja schon mal ausgestiegen
sind aus dem Ausstieg ja es geht um die
letzten drei noch laufenden
Kernkraftwerke in Deutschland diese
Woche werden sie so hat das Kanzler
Scholz im Oktober vergangenen Jahres ja
entschieden definitiv abgeschaltet und
da gibt es für den Wirtschaftsminister
Harbeck auch kein Vertun aber vertut er
sich eventuell mit seiner Einschätzung
dass Deutschland sie wirklich nicht mehr
braucht die Union die FDP und offenbar
auch eine Mehrheit der Deutschen sieht
das jedenfalls anders sie wollen keinen
Ausstieg zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
das Kernkraftwerk Emsland in
Niedersachsen es läuft noch genauso wie
Isa 2 in Bayern und Neckarwestheim in
Baden-Württemberg die drei Atommeiler
gehen Samstag endgültig vom Netz so ist
es politisch beschlossen aber nicht von
jedem politisch so gewollt wir sehen ja
dass ein großer Teil der deutschen
Bevölkerung dafür ist die Kernkraftwerke
jetzt noch befristet weiterlaufen zu
lassen und wir schlagen unseren
Koalitionspartnern eben deshalb vor
zumindest die Kernkraftwerke in einer
Reserve zu behalten ich glaube die
Mehrheit der Deutschen ist dafür aus
ökologischen wie das ökonomischen
Gründen die FDP erhält dafür
Unterstützung von der Union die will
neue Brennstäbe bestellen
Wirtschaftsverbände fürchten um die
Versorgungssicherheit der die
IHK-Präsident meint Deutschland ist
aktuell auf alle verfügbaren
Energieträger angewiesen dazu gehören
für weite Teile unserer Wirtschaft bis
zum Ende der Krise auch die einsetzbaren
Kernkraftwerke das sieht
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck anders
erhält den Ausstieg für unumkehrbar die
Energieversorgungssicherheit in
Deutschland wurde in diesem schwierigen
Winter gewährleistet und wird auch
weiter gewährleistet sein wir setzen mit
dem Atomausstieg um was Union und FDP
2011 beschlossen haben
beschlossen war ein Ende 2022 darüber
haben sich Grüne und FDP aber im
vergangenen Winter so gestritten dass
Olaf Scholz Richtlinienkompetenz
anwenden musste Verlängerung für drei
Meiler bis 15 April diesen Jahres am
Samstag ist dann endgültig Schluss der
Kanzler hat im letzten Oktober ein
Machtwort gesprochen und dieses
Machtwort gilt auch weiterhin dass die
FDP jetzt noch mal ein bisschen Lärm
macht für ihre Position das kann ich
natürlich nachvollziehen
nichtsdestotrotz wird das nichts mehr
helfen denn die Entscheidung ist
gefallen
die letzten drei Meiler werden also
Samstag abgeschaltet die Debatte über
Kernenergie damit aber noch nicht
dieses Skulptur hands across the divide
die in der Grenzstadt Derry steht soll
die Annäherung der Konfliktparteien in
Nordirland symbolisieren und diese
Annäherung hält eisern seit genau 25
Jahren mit dem Karfreitagsabkommen von
1998 wurde die Gewaltspirale tatsächlich
beendet und das ist damals in Belfast
zum Friedensvertrag kam ist wenn man die
Vorgeschichte kennt wirklich fast schon
ein Wunder insbesondere die
proberetischen und die Pro irischen
Paramilitärs hatten eine immerhin
30-Jährige Blutspur hinterlassen fast
4000 Todesopfer über 47.000 verletzte
das sind die nackten Zahlen die die Wut
und Trauer allerdings nicht kaschieren
können bis heute wie Hilke Petersen
berichtet
es ist endlos lange her 51 Jahre der Tag
an dem Harry gargens Schwester Margaret
mit 13 Jahren hier im Westen Belfast
erschossen wird von britischem Militär
mitten im nordirischen Bürgerkrieg 5
Opfer insgesamt das sogenannte
springhill Massaker
in der ersten Untersuchung hörten meine
Eltern dass ihre 13-jährige Tochter ein
bewaffneter Schütze gewesen sei mit
einem Gewehr in der linken Hand das war
so für Sie als sei Margaret noch mal
gestorben dabei hatten sie gedacht sie
würden eine Entschuldigung hören für die
Erschießung ihrer Tochter
die Angehörigen der Opfer von damals
haben jetzt eine neue Untersuchung des
Massakers angestoßen
51 Jahre lang hat die britische
Regierung versucht die Wahrheit über das
Massaker zu unterdrücken durch die
Generationen fragen wir danach meine
Großmutter den Kampf begonnen dann meine
Mutter und ich habe das jetzt übernommen
die Wahrheit muss ans Licht
30 Jahre dauerte der Bürgerkrieg
zwischen protestantischen Unionisten die
im Vereinigten Königreich bleiben wollen
und katholischen Nationalisten die eine
Wiedervereinigung mit der Republik
Irland anstreben fast 4000 sterben
das Karfreitagsabkommen vor 25 Jahren
bringt den Frieden ausgehandelt auch mit
amerikanischer Hilfe
this within fürchterlicher Konflikt der
zu einem Ende gebracht wurde der Friede
ist wert ihn zu bewahren
auch solchen friedensprojekten hat das
Karfreitagsabkommen auf den Weg geholfen
piesling ein Sportcenter an der Grenze
zwischen Irland und Nordirland egal von
welcher Seite alle sollen sich hier
treffen Millionen von der EU machten das
möglich und die Arbeit derer die sich
trauten Angela Graham kommt aus einem
protestantischen Ort und war zu Beginn
vor 20 Jahren hier ziemlich alleine
angefangen habe sahen alle in meinem
Heimatort diese Gegend hier als sehr
republikanisch an ich hatte
Befürchtungen wusste nicht worauf ich
mich da einließ ich habe nachts nicht
gut geschlafen ich hatte einfach Angst
heute in Nordirland traditionell
marschieren sie am Ostern hier
protestantische Gruppen seit dem
Karfreitagsabkommen bleibt so etwas
weitgehend ruhig
doch am Rande republikanischer Märsche
sind eher Anna Splittergruppen mit Brand
setzen unterwegs die Polizei hatte vor
dem Jubiläum des karfreitagsabkommens
vor Attacken gewarnt
Parallelwelten zurück ins Sportcenter an
der Grenze 60 Prozent der Mitglieder
kommen aus Irland 40 aus Nordirland
Trainerin Olga sagt hier interessiere
sich keiner mehr dafür wer woher kommt
die Tür kommt verliert kein Wort über
protestantisch oder katholisch das ist
hier kein Thema auch nicht beim Personal
wir sind eine andere Generation
genau das Feiern sie als Erfolg des
karfreitagsabkommens und US-Präsident
beiden feiert mit morgen Reister nach
Belfast und dann weiter in die sehr
aufgeregte Heimat seiner irischen
Vorfahren
also Präsident beiden hat gleich zwei
Gründe dort hinzufahren zum ein wir
haben es gerade noch mal gehört hat auch
er irische Wurzeln und zum anderen
hatten die Amerikaner unter Präsident
Clinton damals mitgeholfen dass es zu
dem Abkommen kam der damalige britische
Premier Blair sagt sogar dass sie das
alles ohne die Unterstützung der
Amerikaner nicht geschafft hätten und
mit friedensvorderungen beginnen jetzt
auch deine Nachrichten Gundula auch an
diesem Ostermontag haben sich wieder
Tausende an den traditionellen
friedensmärschen gegen Krieg und
Aufrüstung beteiligt die Initiatoren
sprechen von insgesamt 120 Aktionen mit
mehreren 10.000 Demonstranten wie hier
in Frankfurt forderten sie ein Ende des
russischen Krieges gegen die Ukraine und
Friedensverhandlungen getragen werden
die Ostermärsche von regionalen
Friedensgruppen Gewerkschaften und der
Linken
Russland setzt seinen Krieg gegen die
Ukraine mit massiven Angriffen fort
während die Hintergründe der
Veröffentlichung geheime US-Dokumente
zum Krieg weiter unklar sind der Kreml
sie durch die Berichte einmal mehr die
Verwicklung Washingtons bestätigt
erstmals seit mehr als einem Monat haben
die Ukraine und Russland wieder Kriegs
Gefangene ausgetauscht je 100 Militär
Angehörige wurden in ihre Heimat
zurückgebracht
US-Präsident beiden will bei der
Präsidentenwahl im November 2024 erneut
als Kandidat für die Demokraten antreten
allerdings sei er zu einer offiziellen
Ankündigung noch nicht bereit sagte der
80-Jährige am Rande einer
osterveranstaltung des Weißen Hauses
bei einer Schießerei in einem
Bankgebäude im US-Bundesstaat Kentucky
sind vier Menschen getötet worden auch
der mutmaßliche Schütze sei tot teilte
die Polizei Louis will mit Ermittlungen
hätten ergeben dass der Mann aktuell
oder früher bei der Bank angestellt
gewesen sei allen schusswaffenattacken
zum Trotz wird das Waffenrecht in den
USA nicht verschärft
die Gewalt im Nahen Osten dauert an die
israelischen Golanhöhen wurden von
syrischem Gebiet aus beschossen
daraufhin griff die ist der israelische
Luftwaffe Ziele in dem feindlichen
Nachbarland an ihm wärst ja Oderland ist
bei einem israelischen Militäreinsatz
ein 15-Jähriger Palästinenser getötet
worden nach Armee Angaben ein
Terrorverdächtiger
in Berlin hat der
staatsschutzermittlungen wegen des
Verdachts der Volksverhetzung
aufgenommen nach mutmaßlich
judenfeindlichen Parolen bei einer
propalästinensischen Demonstration dabei
waren am Samstag nach Angaben von
Beobachtern antisemitische rufe zu hören
die deutsch-israelische Gesellschaft
spricht von einer Israel
hassdemonstration und hat Strafanzeige
erstattet
über das Osterwochenende haben viele
Flüchtlinge die gefährliche Überfahrt
über das Mittelmeer Richtung Italien
gewagt in nur 24 Stunden kamen auf
Lampedusa fast 1.000 Menschen an
darunter viele Kinder die Erstaufnahme
Lager auf der Insel sind überfüllt
insgesamt kamen seit Jahresbeginn mehr
als 28.000 Menschen nach Italien viermal
so viele wie im gleichen
Vorjahreszeitraum
[Musik]
wir haben keine Lösung
wir haben Lieder
wir haben keine Lösung wir haben Lieder
und was für welche es ist einfach ein
Fest sich dieser Schönheit im traurigen
hinzugeben solange Element of Crime
einen dabei quasi an die Hand nehmen und
das tut die Band seit nunmehr 38 Jahren
in einer
unverwechselbaren Art denn sie sind sich
und ihrer Musik in all den Jahren immer
treu geblieben chris hat Läpple über das
15 Studioalbum morgens um vier und ein
beseeltes Publikum in der Hauptstadt
ach da sind sie wieder Element of Crime
am Abend in Berlin alles ganz neu und
doch so vertraut
wir sind alleine und wir sind zwei
wir brauchen dabei und das ist gut denn
die Zeiten
werden will
unscharf mit Katze morgens um 4 Uhr da
ist man müde oder wach
ist die Stadt Element of Crime mit ihrem
15 Studioalbum treue Wegbegleiter seit
vier Jahrzehnten Experten für
langweilige Sonntag Nachmittag habe
Liebesschmerz und Einsamkeit
morgens um vier die richtige Zeit das
Album zu hören
insofern ist eigentlich jede Zeit eine
gute Zeit auf morgens um 4 Uhr am besten
wenn man Zeit hat für mich also das ist
ja wichtig machen wir ein bisschen Musik
hört es ist ganz gut ein bisschen Zeit
zu haben man kann es auch nebenbei beim
Bügeln hören ob beim Bügeln zu Hause
oder abhängen in der Kneipe keine andere
Combo verkörpert diesen speziellen Mix
aus Romantik und Melancholie gewürzt mit
Gelassenheit und Ironie neu dabei Sänger
Tobias bamborsch gefunden der
jungkultband Isolation Berlin er singt
im Duett mit Altmeister Regener Brüder
werden ihren Deckel bezahlen Flugzeuge
werden den Himmel bemalen
und dann kommst du wieder in der Kunst
ist eben das traurige kann auch schön
sein das ist schön und werden dem
richtigen Leben ist das traurige eben
nicht schön und dass diese gerade diese
Funktion von Kunst ist glaube ich sehr
wichtig dieses tröstende als das Leben
zu feiern wozu das eben auch gehört
kaum zu glauben Element of Crime vor 40
Jahren damals Rotz freche Newcomer Band
mit Songs auf Englisch doch die
Kreuzberger Hinterhof Helden werden
erwachsen sie singen auf Deutsch der
Durchbruch
kritiker bemängeln die Elements machen
Musik für depressiver ein anderer
behauptet die bandlinge als wolle sie
das Schieben eines Rollators vertun
kann ich nicht viel zu sagen ich werde
ich bin der letzte der Kritiker
kommentiert wir bekommen die Welt nicht
schlauer machen du kannst sie nicht
besser machen in dem Sinne dass sie
weniger der Scheißhaufen ist aber wir
können Sie wir können Sie ein bisschen
schöner machen wenn dann Sven Regner ist
eine Trompete ansetzt ist das als wäre
ein alter Freund oder die beste Freundin
zu Gast
das Leben ist wie es ist
augenzwinkernd und nervend mach einfach
das Beste draus was nichts Besseres geht
als als Musik machen und auch für uns
auch nichts besseres als Elemente Fragen
zu machen das ist nicht falsch als
Musiker im Stiefel zu sterben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Fehler noch die Wetter Aussichten die
wieder mehr Regen bringen morgen nur im
Osten zunächst regnerisch später überall
wechseln bewölkt mit Schauern oder
kurzen Gewittern aber auch sonnigen
Abschnitten bei starkem Westwind 10 bis
15 Grad am Mittwoch 9 bis 16 Grad und
verbreitet Regen auch am Donnerstag sehr
unbeständig erst am Freitag wieder
häufiger Sonne und bis zu 15 Grad
und wir sehen uns hier morgen wieder
nicht irgendwie und gegen vier sondern
um viertel vor zehn machen sie es gut wo
auch immer sie sind tschüss
[Musik]